ja ich begrüße ich als herzlich zur die
besitzungen in der wir uns vorgenommen
haben nämlich immersion oder auch ist
elite computerspiele die version ist ein
weiteren begriff inversion betrifft
nicht nur kommt unterschrieben also
version bekommen eben auch und vor allem
in einer studie vor
aber eben nicht nur in version gibt es
auch in anderen formen der ästhetik und
das war also heute das thema sein
und ich begrüße die teilnehmer kann man
auch im livestream dieses amt auch hier
den screen sehen sollten jahren sie denn
jetzt also ich begrüße die teilnehmer
und denke heute kein wirklich
satte dinge kommentieren ich denke dass
das was ich heute und anbietet
wir sind anleihen und genauer als
jedenfalls heute geht es um die version
und möchte zu beginn möglich und ihn
ein kurzes wissmann ich möchte dass die
vitalität quiz machen hand geht das
schon gesehen nicht als sie mich in
christenhand und zwar habe man hier um
die fans sind virtuelle gegenstände
alter hase besitzen kausale kräfte es
gibt immer eine oder mehr möglich
sie besitzen keine kräfte wie ihre
bedeutung ist von tieren die
vertrauensbasis simulieren die
wirklichkeit und was würden sie sagen
was ist das richtige ja gesagt 12 trifft
zu anderen meinungen wieso nicht dass
dritte nicht die situation der
wirklichkeit wohl schon zwei gewonnenen
dritten hinzu
also ich sags sie haben recht ziel ist
es richtig aber warum warum ich mal
berufen
also irgendwas hat nicht so der
das sehen ist es nicht wichtig
offensichtlich bedeutet simulation noch
nicht eine gute simulation bedeute zwar
nicht dass es eine virtuelle realität
ist eine simulation erschließt nicht
realität wie auch immer wird
worin unterscheidet sich digitale tel
von digitalisierten digitalisierung ist
die technische seite der digitalität
digitalität meinte reflexionen auf der
digitalisierung zählt die qualität ist
die technische seite meditation aber
ihre zehn eine oder mehrere
entwicklungen ist die digitale
identitäten zu seiner identität
ermitteln die köpfe die tanten man die
reflexe leute die vernichtung
philosophische vielleicht oder
kulturellen zehnte italy technisch sehr
gut
nicht geschüttelt und zwar zu recht
das ist dann habe jetzt einfach ein
bisschen ganz gemacht jetzt nächste
frage was zeigen wir das internet
philosoph gestaut es ist transzendentale
sofern es die bedingung der möglichkeit
von medialität ist dann zu einer art
grundbedürfnis wie wasser und strom
geworden ist die amischen jahren recht
gehört das habe ich ja eingeführt run
zentrale bedingung die möglichkeiten
erkannt
der nächste frage es der inbegriff des
mediums durch seine raum und
zeitlosigkeit nächste ja das hat robert
dreyfuss hat es ist ein analoges medium
nicht über texte street und bildet damit
unserer assoziatives denken dann liegt
jemand es ist dezentral und auf
demokratische weise in jedem fall finden
also demokratisch ein problem warum man
demokratie gut machen und es ist ist man
nicht überall nicht allen regionen der
welt ist es natürlich zu bringen aber
wenn es zu kennen ist das ist wirklich
schon
mit meinen viele lassen einen richtigen
zugang aber wenn man halt drin letzten
verletzt sein kann man seine
meinungsäußerung identität verschleiern
und so weiter
was verstehen wir unter information
daten tauschen b positionen struktur sie
interessante bisschen mehr als was es
jedenfalls nicht dass erst die erste
daten auf das keine nation
rauschen ist einfach da kenne ich nix
raus aus den branchen und des antrags
ist gestartet
da muss man seine position alle
strukturen noch mal eine kognitive
struktur jahre alt ist es wichtig alle
also es hat was in den kompetenten zu
tun
wissen sie noch was eine produktion des
beschreibt gemeinden wollen dass so
etwas in einem das sachs gemacht werden
kann oder auch was war heizwert fädelt
als einsatz oder eine behauptung ein
urteil in these eine sprachliche wir
haben immer aus der sonntag zustimmen
bedient war das anschreiben an die la
hei zum beispiel fragen sind keine
position bin ich frei wie ist das wetter
schön dann kann man zu sagen ja und ich
weiß nicht aber gerade als solche kann
ich wahr oder falsch seien
man kann da wird man aber natürlich
solche fragen stellen zb eine person
sind sie kriminellen oder sind sie sind
sie in einem kommentar
wir haben immer dass man bei den
personenwagen denn dann und dann wird es
ein bisschen
natürlich die es falsch gewesen
noch wagen natürlich denjenigen der
großmarkt wird gar keine möglichkeit
lässt
daraus zogen entkommen aus dieser
bestellung das betrifft jetzt aber mein
anderes seminar form betrifft eigentlich
dieses seminar oppositionelle strukturen
würde ich sagen ja
um interessante daten ich denke das
interesse informationen doch mit dem
rezipienten zusammen für den etwas von
interesse ist
und jetzt die frage inwiefern ist
künstliche intelligenz intelligent durch
musste erkennen kann eine art von
begriff meiner sache geboren werden
deshalb weiche haben und sie gegen war
wieder richtig künstliche neuronale
netze klassifizieren daten korrekt hier
in künstlichen neuronalen netze besitzen
selbstbewusstsein künstliche neuronale
netze treffen korrekte entscheidung
selbst auch nichts gegessen als
künstliche neuronale netze klassifiziert
muss ich sagen ja dass damit die wissen
zu bekämpfen ist wichtig klassifizieren
können könnte
ich glaube schon aber es hängt immer
davon ab was man unter 1 verstehen aber
klassifizieren kategorisiert wissen
intelligenz leistung zu bestimmen dem
urteil ist gas machen kann künstlichen
einsetzen
könnte ich mir noch eine letzte treffen
korrekte entscheidungen ja das ist die
spannende frage richtig spannend zu
werden
chancen hatte und sie anwältin bereitet
weil wir haben gezielt die zweite frage
schon mit den zwei optionen schon mit ja
beantwortet und da aus dieser differenz
der 2 und möglichkeiten der film nicht
klassifizieren ist es einen richtigen
entscheidungen treffen zusammen in den
weißen haus
neben pkw klassen werden
wir auch zustimmen mit dem korrekt ist
schon bewährt wir haben einfach dass es
stimmt also einfach ganz objektiv da
kommt was richtig ist dabei das
funktioniert kann man kann auch falsch
klassifiziert
man kann sich einfach irgendwas falsch
und etwas worden und ich kann es nicht
sagen
vogel ist ein fall von säugetieren
vögeln oder andere ist ein säugetier das
wäre die falsche klasse ergänzung wenn
ich sagen würde neben zb in einem fuchs
ist ein solcher tiere wären richtigen
klasse dazu dass eine korrekte
klassifikation korrekte im unterhaus und
dann begriffen
die frage ist nicht ob damit begriff
auch gesessen wird gefahren ist
man kann sagen wenn man alle berge
machen können alles richtig
klassifiziert und einfallen könnte man
sagen hat zum auf- und begriffen aber
eine korrekte entscheidung helfen ist
natürlich was an das also klassifizieren
entscheidend wir haben gesehen wo
entscheidungen müssen gute gründe wir
wollen spieler oder der
entscheidungsträger
das wird so weit gefasst und so
verbessert dass man auf alles erwarten
kann
also wie gesagt dass wir zu meinem
vorschlag aber sie sehen das ist ganz
offen und das getan so dann machen wir
ein bisschen weiter wirklich außerdem
noch mal kurz als christen in die gern
als intelligent des betrags das quiz
oder wenn sie schreiben immer bitte mit
mir absprechen ich habe jetzt auch ein
fluggast habe ich ihnen die liste
aufgestellt
und weitere informationen was ist
informationen wie funktionieren und
können sie sich aber noch im netz im
vergleich zum gehirn können sie unser
denken simulieren oder gar ersetzen also
können sie im eigenes gehirn entwickeln
inwiefern ist das internet philosophen
stelle waren besteht seine strukturen
und seine ethischen blieben
worin besteht der unterschied zwischen
realität und virtualität in simulationen
bekomme einfach mal ganz kurz
versprechen eigentlich von der großtante
unterscheidung und wodurch zeichnet sich
die ästhetik der computerspiele aus im
gegensatz zu anderen formen der ästhetik
zb im gegensatz zur literarischen
fiktion im gegensatz zum hörspiel
gegensatz zur musik die wie rassistisch
war im gegensatz zum theaterspiel zum
drama und zum fehlen natürlich auch zum
zum hollywoodfilm unternehmen oder zum
fernsehen als das ist die ganze zeit
auch die werte auch eingeben die
biografie habe schon gesagt finden sie
auf dem rasen gehören menschlichen
vitalität wenn das aktuelle mobile
können immer aktualisieren und man hier
oft sie verlinkt ich auch direkt mit
reinen können jemand der lenz
institutionen virtualität und möchte
ihnen ein paar beispiele bringen möchten
immer kurz darüber diskutieren ich habe
noch keine zusammenfassung besteht aber
sind ganz entscheidendes thema geld
scheint bitcoins youtube abnimmt und
digitale identitäten und jetzt
unternehmen vw volkswahl inwiefern
existiert volkswagen fragt der havarie
oder premiere ist der abi dieser johann
kowar
diese
tonne schriftsteller der gerade die
ganze bestsellerlisten erobert kennt es
eine kurze geschichte der menschheit und
darin schreibe ich beim volkswagen und
existiert irgendwie auch aber auf eine
ganz andere weise wie es zum beispiel
ein steinen ab und deswegen kann niemand
sagen auf unternehmen oder auch die
katholischen kirchen existieren aber auf
eine andere weise als apfel und auch auf
eine andere weise also dieses gedanken
über die existenz meisterschaften er in
gedanken oder kaviar mit der photo
mentalität zu sein als dem
physikalischen man hört den volkswagen
auf zu existieren
wie lange im stil im volkshaus wie und
unter welchen bedingungen würde
volkswagen der auflösung zu existieren
das müsste man machen damit volkswagen
nicht mehr existiert das war ja knapp
davor dass es nicht mehr existiert also
es gab ja
die situation sie wissen mit dem diesen
abgangs die manipulationsmöglichkeiten
gemacht der nachkriegszeit gedacht
die neue zahl wenn man sie fragte was
müsste passieren damit volkswagen nicht
mehr existieren wenn man das zentrum
zerstören würde was wir nicht wollen
würde es noch existieren natürlich genau
wenn wir diesen motor sport verlegen
würden dann würde unseren existiert was
müsste man machen kann was müsste man
machen eine person müssten sie haben
eine person die müsste nur was machen
all wertung und wichtig dass ich meine
es gibt mehrere bei einer zu berichten
zum beispiel ein recht an der richter
die müsste ein urteil fällen wenn das
passiert ist und dann wäre volkswagen
nicht mittag oder der wahlvorstand
höchstens volkswagen auf die lösung ist
einfach auf die erklärung
da gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten
aber sie sehen das recht nicht mehr von
der physikalischen existenz abhängig von
der laufzeit
ob jetzt volkswagen
also fasst die aktie so hat sie
mittlerweile zehn sind auch sowas wird
nation vom wochen existiert deutschland
von in deutschland oder genau anfangen
so ganz schwierige viele stilisierung
länder mit vielen idealisierung viele
müssten mystifizierung erzählen und
narrativ über die identitäten ganz
spannende frage gebrochen man nicht
wirklich existiert die classic erstmals
begannen sie das ändern wird auf welche
weise existenz nur indem er den
kunstwerken heißt eigentlich recht
gewährt es ist irgendwie existieren sie
ja schon dann würde schon sagen dass
existiert und gefragt wie existiert ist
und man könne jetzt nicht sagen sie
existiert durch ihren geist der geister
das geist sauber hat herr grüner ob ich
habe darüber aufsatz geschrieben
aber da ist ziemlich nervös und haben
nicht richtig greift gibt es einen geist
talent woche den geist des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts wie lange sie zierte er
jahrelang das zwanzigste jahrhundert
existierte wobei der vielleicht ein
bisschen ins 21
und darüber berichten und andersrum
das zwanzigste ist es kurze jahr das 20
jahrhundert war geil der von
1918 1989 und bislang dem 19 jahrhundert
kinder viel länger als 20 sekunden
dauerte gar nicht 100 jahre verkürzen
und der geist zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ist heute auch zum beispiel merkbaren
bei mir zum beispiel gleich wenn wir
jetzt auf die computer später eingehen
ganz leise zehn gegenstimmen computer
schwierig sein und laut hardt ii gut und
so weiter so fort und jetzt dass man
diese party hut aus dem spielten scape
1007 nur dollar
oxford ernteten virtuality 17 fielen da
gibt es einen aufsatz das duo wir leben
hier was gelesen haben die folien finden
so wie immer hier unter dem video
beschreibungstext sagte dieser autor
diese frage ist klassischen
computerbefehle von tausenden study of
religious and philosophy kämpfen für
puristische antwort kein sex ist und
hautkrebs ist in israel change partners
und thoma just questions marktrisiken ab
6 der auftritt von physikern property
and how
aktivurlaub also handelte sich bei
virtuellen gegenständen um gegenstände
und objekte natürlich aber sind nicht
physikalisch und er kann weiter fragen
sind das ereignis sind wir werden sehr
registriert in verwaltung sofort und das
land spannende frage frau hier gibt es
aus der verwaltung fragen was ist meins
gemordet systems operations und events
es gibt ja nicht nur virtuelle
gegenstände wie der blauen party gut
gebrauchen virtuelle handlungen zb in
einem online rollenspiel gibt es
ereignis gehandelt
und wie fern besitzen die eine realität
warum sind es nicht nur simulation also
da kann man die gesamte ausschreibung
jetzt möchte ich einfach noch hierüber
sichtbar gemacht geben die mir sehr sehr
gut erscheint die habe ich jetzt
entwickelt das ist meine these wir
können dort diskutieren
ich glaube wir müssen unsere chancen
gespielt und geredet werden
drei fälle ohne physikalische realität
zum beispiel ihr die fernbedienung gibt
es die mentalitäten macht unsere
gedanken und qual der und was auch immer
und die sind eben nicht dem tisch dann
auch nicht direkt erklärt das
musikalisch sie werden zwar wenn das
physikalische zeugenaussagen aber es ist
die klasse zulieferer auf reduzieren
die highlands eindruck kann ich nicht in
seinem in seiner komik weiter die
motivation als zentrale nicht damit
erklären ob nicht jemand erklären der
blind ist da bin ich sagt ja diese diese
neuronen vorher
dann gibt es noch hirnaktivität um ihren
überzeugen da ist die rot wird ein
blinder sagen
damit kann ich gar nichts deswegen haben
die mentalen und jetzt gibt's noch eine
virtuelle welt wie zb glaube im haushalt
oder wie zum beispiel volksbank oder wie
zb 6 ich glaube das ist ganz viel
freiheit wieder haben die trendwende mit
meinen überlegungen und hat das ist
neuland wichtig ist zu sagen dass die
virtuelle gehe ich aus dem zweiten natur
schon entstanden zweiten tour ist kultur
die kultur ist im wesentlichen von euch
aus gezeigt dass es virtualität dort die
kultur ohne virtualität ohne unternehmen
ohne geld ohne kunst die auch nur
virtuell existieren er wäre keine kultur
und hier gibt es die verbindung für zwei
im naturzoo
noch interessanter punkt des metzinger
gewissen weil es einen roten zu
verstehen
auch raum und zeit wäre meine thesen wo
sind die gedanken nicht in meinem kopf
sie werden in meinem kopf erzeugt das
sind dort würde ich sagen und auch
zeitlich existierte gedanken
ich kann zwar sagen zu diesem zeitpunkt
hatte ich diesen gedanken aber ja der
gedanke wann existiert
ich habe jetzt sofort ist daran gedacht
an dem gedanken ich habe dem mieter und
ich habe etwas an erfahrung
aber das ist was anderes als eine
existenz eines apfels der nach einer
woche pauli holt also besonders deutlich
wird der raum ist normal das entziehe
etwas physikalisches und auch das
virtuelle wird erzeugen werden
ermöglicht eine testversion zb geld geld
schon ist was physikalisches ist der
träger weil man sein gehirn etwas
musikalisches erzeugen
unsere gedanken und die server und
computer sind auch was musikalisches
physikalisch beschreibbare
die erzeugen mit dem zwischenschritt
noch des algorithmus ort des cross da
der code ist auch eine interessante
sache bekommt erscheint mir zwischen
metall und physikalischen und
physikalisches dem plus physikalischen
street werden mit algorithmus die sich
musikalisch auf den server
dieser raum ist das mentale belastung
opposition glauben antwortet opposition
also mit italien eine gewisse verbindung
gar nicht meine sache
und jetzt wirkt sich die realität ich
glaube der fiktion der großen dichte die
figuren gehandelt haben den
existierenden wirklich eine simulation
und eine gewisse das sind formen eine
realität und bei mir herr professor
buchheim in der diskussion
reaktionen können wir uns ja auch noch
nie beziehen also insofern müssen sich
auch dann existieren wir können uns alle
darauf einigen wer handelt ist in
gewissen hinsicht
wir wissen nicht genau wie groß handelt
ist ist 1 70 und 60
ja wir wissen nicht welche haarfarbe er
hatte steht nicht drin war sehr sehr
schwierig listen geben standen
vollständig zu bestimmen
deswegen ist seine existenz nicht ganz
so klar
simulationen ist insofern nicht realität
weil der begriff schon sagt wir
simulieren nur und fiktion eine
infektion des künstlich das heißt
erdichtet wir denken und etwas was aber
einem begriff bereit gerade nicht
existieren sollte zwecks qualifikation
nicht glauben
ich habe eine frage zur simulation es
gibt ja rechnung und den
simulationsberechnungen die nutzt man
einen
das konzept ist sehr sehr nah war sie
einst zu angesehen sie haben mir wichtig
wird es anders formulieren
die simulation ist nicht die realität
habe die simulation hilft uns und wir
können bestimmte die mit durch prüfen
und wir können direkte schlüsse
entziehen oder indirekt erkenntnisse
gewinner für das geld aus dem verkauf
genommen
aber das ist eben noch was anderes als
zu sagen die simulation ist eine regel
seien die simulation ist mein modell uns
realität sieht einfach dass die
fokussiert auch bestimmte eigenschaften
installiert und spielt das größe und sie
tritt an die stelle der realität und
haben nur als seine verwaltung und
winden oder als modell
entscheidungsrunden marco pirani student
aber es ist ein schritt machen können
daraus mögliche erkenntnisse für die
realität als insofern ist es nicht bloß
eine illusion
und auch die musik zu der viele hätte
die situation ganz links ist scheiße
und dann bin ich es auch keine fiktion
[Musik]
das ist aber jetzt nur angebot zur
diskussion ist noch lange nicht können
vollkommen auf twitter mein vertrag nach
dieser tagung über digitale täten
extremen werte ist ein bisschen weiter
ausführen weil das scheint mir ganz
zentrales zum beliebten wird schon so
wenn es hat hier eine stellung der
schilder youtube kürze hier auf die
lowcost einen kommentar zu diesem thema
braucht zeit
die reden virtualität eine rolle spielen
denn sie sagt ich würde der aussage für
sprechen wollen das virtualität als
nicht grau zeitlich verstanden und es
mag durchaus einleuchtend sein dass das
virtuelles wird ausgedehnt ist
inzwischen eines politischen raumes
auftaucht
auf grundlage einer nicht alltäglichen
geometrien dort wie man sie bei riemann
findet und wie sie in den vergangenen
jahrhunderten der zugeschnitten werden
agentur zugrunde gelegt ließ sich jenes
was die virtuellen durchaus verstehen
als raum zeit und den stars der blaue
party gut aus und es fehlt hier ein
gefaltetes servicegedanke eingehalten
das gehirn die leipzig durchaus
betroffen
nach jemand eine lösung bestehen zeit
beschäftigt weilt im urlaub ist wie mir
scheint dass konsumentenvertrauens wie
es die replikation für anschauen und
scheint eine lehrstelle besonders
hinfallen die verwirrung über realität
des virtuellen auch eine gemeinsame
basis zu stellen wir behaupten ein
bisschen virtuelle planung ist eindeutig
das räume ich es nicht kann im spiel
anschauen und aufsätzen und mich mit dem
ideal des virtuellen raumes des spieles
bewegen spannenden ich muss sagen ich
kenne mich zu wenig mit diesem lied das
er die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
das betrifft nicht nur die spezielle
kann nämlich zu wenige ordner und muss
sagen das ist es ja bisher wissen
interessanter und amir scheines in
analogie zu sein
also es könnte sich analoge verstehen
lassen wie dieser nicht öffentlichen
raum
ich habe jetzt darauf geantwortet habe
er sich bedanken
wir geben ganz wichtig ich denke dass
es sollten servern ihre harten rechten
verhältnis von gedanken die erzeugerin
katalog erscheint das gedanken genauso
wenig räume wie es virtuelle teams sind
obwohl sie von raum zeitlichen dingen
erzeugt werden denn wie groß und schwer
ist denn zum beispiel glauben schaden
und ums leben das ist allerhöchstens
größe an den seitenfenstern ständig also
durch den code sozusagen das ist ein weg
da gibt's vector und geweckt man könnte
aber meines erachtens von einer
virtuellen räumlichkeiten zu erstechen
gewissen konventionen spielzeiten
man könnte auch sagen wird euer
virtuelles dieser sehr engagierte nutzer
dann auch noch geantwortet dann können
sie gerne nachlesen alles viel obst
finde ich sehr sehr glücklich dass wir
in den nutzer mitmachen vergessen dass
seine gedanken und dann können sie gerne
hier
engagierten nutzern werden auch
antworten
also wir dann nochmal den nutzer und
jetzt thema der heutigen sitzung jetzt
geht es also zum heutigen thema und
andere fragen zur aktualität spannendes
thema interessanten tausewald scheint
für mich der central der virtualität des
der schlüsselbegriffe das ganze thema
für sich zu erschließen und um die
beziehung zur zweiten natur die kultur
zugleich herzustellen und in letzter
punkt mir scheint dass die welt in
anderen zeiten geben wird zum ersten mal
virtualität virtuelle realität so
plastisch vor augen dass ihre
ökonomische signifikanten deutlich wird
solange ist er mit geld und sonstige
dinge können wir zu tun haben glaubt war
die virtualität
und zwar deswegen weil das ganze recht
eine physikalische gegenstand verbunden
war also der geldschein kann man die
handlung und man die ganz lange einen
denkfehler oder einen kurzschluss eine
subvention könnte man sagen dass man
dort gewährt oft mit geldscheinen
produziert weil sie doch sagt der geld
hat diesen wert der repräsentierten der
matthäus trainierten iren der verwirrten
ihnen auch dank der gemeinschaft aber er
hat den wert eigentlich nicht so ein
zeichen den konventionen und dadurch
dass wir in der zweiten advent immer
noch zu wasser und der handhabung das
physikalisch ist glaube ich dass wir die
ganzen dimensionen der virtualität noch
gar nicht richtig sehen und erste
möglichkeit der künstlichen wirtschaft
also digitalen erzeugung bekommen wir
die situation wo wir von diesen raum
zeiten physikalischen dingen ganz
abstrakt wäre natürlich haben wir jedoch
solche tablets aber ich würde nie sagen
dass das tablet irgendwas macht oder ist
wenn wir uns im raum geblieben sind wie
jetzt dann die version und das scheint
mir jetzt ein interessanter fahrer der
unter mobil zu sein dass wir zum ersten
mal
wirklich die ganze ökologische bedeutung
der virtualität kennenlernen und von dem
anderen und theologen nämlich dem tragen
und der physikalischen unter mobile
unterscheiden durch diese technischen
integration
wir kommen jetzt in ganz neuen
technologischen zweig der sich
unterstützt und das war glaube ich der
zweite natur durch die bindung an die
materialen zeit wie zb einem geldschein
so wichtig heute geht es um die version
oder um das thema bewerbung unterstützen
gerne verstandes thema sie wissen wenn
sie mal schauen der umsatz mit
computerspielen ist gigantisch der
größte markt ist ein klub aus china
damit kommen die usa und deutschland
kommen
platz dann kommt mehr an platz drei und
dann kommt deutschland auf platz vier
und dann kommt england also ganz dicht
die sind diesen spielfreudiger die haben
ja weniger bevölkerung als wir die
engländer england und diese lieder
aufnahmen und aber interessant dass
neben der markt asien besonders großes
interesse
ja wir haben ein paar live in die ferne
unterschreiben sich computerspiele von
anderen formen von spielen und
kulturellen produkten wie etwa literatur
und film was bedeutet immersion das ist
der schlüsselbegriff für die ästhetik
der digitalität das bedeutet und wie
fernsehen und computerspiele ein welche
mittel gelingt version ich habe es schon
einige sagten version suns eintauchen
welchen mitteln den ästhetischen
technischen
gelingt diese im herzen zu lassen
niefern stellen computerspielen
virtuelle realität nicht einfach mal
simulationen infektionen da dass die
frage ob wikipedia ist man ein trick
schafft nicht den versionen
fachsprachlich eintauchen
die meere der welt an später beschreibt
die ihm durch eine umgebung der
virtuellen realität evl hervorrufen
effekt der das bewusstsein des process
solution stimuli ausgesetzt zu sein so
weit in den hintergrund treten lässt
dass die virtuelle umgebung als real im
grunde ist er gerade dimension besucher
mit anfang präsenz so hier setzt was
ganz interessantes vorhanden nämlich im
geht es nur 100 als reale gefunden als
ob also klar dieser besetzung mehrere
virtuelle realitäten keine realität als
diese kartenspiele werde keine weil es
nur als gefunden das heißt auch nicht
dass er ist
perfekt sind die jungen das ist was
anderes als die party mit der 1007 hat
hier scheinen wir noch ein bisschen
unterschätzt wird unterschied zum
passiven filmischen version um einen
bequemen sessel sitzt und popcorn ist
etwas ungesundes dringend erlaubt die
virtuelle realität eine interaktion mit
der wirkung wodurch eine wesentlich
höhere intensität der inversion
verwaltung die frage kann ein hoher grad
an interaktion kann der dazu führen dass
es nicht mehr mit einer simulation
aktionäre sollen mit einem gutschein
werden weiter sagte er sie wird
innovationen umgebungen die
merseburgerin wenn es dem benutzer
ermöglicht wird direkt mit dieser zu
interagieren
die kelten cfdt ankommen mit
entsprechend interaktions haben ist ein
beispiel für ein solches system im
gegensatz hierzu steht gewicht intensiv
im virtuelle realität in einem 3d cad
system welches auf einem pc betrieben
wird
also das sind jetzt ganz deutschland
angeliefert handelt es sich dabei
wirklich um realität und virtuelle
[Musik]
zusammenhalt jetzt auch warum läuft ja
auch immer wieder davon gesprochen dass
die leute die da abgelaufen sind auch in
seiner virtuellen realität ich zu meinen
hier ist beseelt von der bam bestens auf
auf der welt die filme erzeugt nicht
mehr
sie haben damit völlig wichtig vom
getroffen haben und den usa gab das
entkommen bei reis kronen
das war 2002 gebote brechen und das
wahrhaben
das war ein computer steht meines
wissens dass dort als basis diente so
dass dieses szenario modell
auch deutschland war ein computerspiel
sachsen sind und das ist natürlich auch
eine ethische problematik der
computerspiele
es gibt ein neues buch kritik der
spieler nicht mag auch an linke und
letzte fall aktiv ist nicht gefährdet
ist dabei dass technologische effekt
unabhängig davon auch die virtuelle
realität existiert und nicht die
lebenswichtig sagt psychologisch sich
darin verlieren oder die welt vertauscht
da nicht mehr raus kommen uns diese
künstlichen welt wie es natürlich auch
sein kann wenn man sie sind comics liest
oder produkte film irgendwann kommt man
da nicht kann man hier die realität der
fiktion schalten wir können das nicht
psychologisch jedenfalls dann wenn
eigene realität das ist auch gefährlich
werden kann je nachdem was für
computerspiele sich handeln nicht alle
computerspiele sind ja jetzt da ganz
einwandfrei spiel der computerspiele
wenn die gerade diese version des in den
staaten sind indiziert worden zumindest
in dieser zeit von der gründung sind
bundesprüfstelle für
was einem bundesprüfstelle die diese
spiele dann indiziert haben ihn zu
lieben oder zu viel gewalt ansteigen
machen das ist natürlich auch ein
ethisches problem
inwiefern wir durch die leute version
verleitet oder manipuliert werden können
daneben dieser welt auch so dass diese
3d sicht in diese welt wäre dann so zwei
wichtige punkte als auch psychologischer
moralischer und weniger jetzt konto
logisch von bedeutung ist aber es ist
sehr wichtig dass wir die chance nicht
nehmen und jetzt möchte ich ihnen kurz
der die kleine geschichte des
computerspiels sehr wohl im
revolutionsgeschichte des computers hier
habe ich teilweise auch selbst
mitgemacht und ich spreche hier
teilweise ist ein augenzeuge die
augenzeugin
ja das war bei einer wette also aktive
nutzer er war zuerst akteure ja ich bin
rezipient untergeht
also lieber zwei versionen jeweils ist
können jetzt ein paar bildbeispielen
auch bewegt wird es in chips ich hoffe
dass ich das hier auch der weg
sie finde es kursieren viele bilder oder
computerspielen chronologisch
präsentiert jetzt schauen sie mal für
sich jeweils dieser und anderen fragen
sich wie wird dimensionen allerdings
einbeziehen des nutzers dem bildschirm
sitzt jeweils realisiert ästhetisch und
auch technologische also wenn ich nicht
im raum und in welchen öffentlichen raum
wird sie entwickelt auf dieser
bildfläche welche bewegungen für den
staat nicht geben
neben interventionen für eine
interaktion statt des nutzers mit dem
mit dem entitäten auf dem bildschirm mit
figuren und spielen eine rolle
und wichtig lichtverhältnissen springen
da wurde vielleicht auch ganz wichtig
licht und dann die fahrsimulation
fiktion und in virtuelle realität um was
handelt es sich dabei den jeweiligen
gibt es manche dieser gespräche die ich
dann plötzlich virtuelle realität sind
wenn es manche spiele nicht sind und man
sich diese kategorien immer vor augen zu
halten werden und dann in den sinfonien
darauf eine antwort zu geben wir hier
schreibt auch der nutzer auf youtube das
komme bei einem massaker hat sogar
selbst ein videospiel inspiriertes ein
bisschen verzögert
ziel des supercopa sie hier kontra seine
ethik debatte auf das ist genau der
punkt gewählt habe zugenommen
also müssen wir alles ein bisschen
ethisch kommunisten deswegen gibt es
jetzt auch einiges zu bieten darunter
stimmgewalt doch irgendwie logisch
jedenfalls ökologisch bin ich mir sicher
auch psychologisch von computerspiele
ganz großes zu kreative kraft der
emotionen muskel sagen wir mal damit
andere holen und haben lange aber jetzt
haben sind auch sehr interessiert
wie heißt diese spiele
ausrichter ist es habe ich da schon
gelebt sagen sie nichts weiter sagen
nichts weiter
und ich nicht genau es ist wissen sie es
und es 172 dabei ein klang nicht geboren
es waren ultimative familien spielt das
konnte man die phase einsteck modul was
man an den fernseher anschließen und
dann hatte man das
komische steuerungs träger und das
kleine mädchen mit denen der eine diesen
diese torhüter steuerte das die anderen
und das natürlich nicht oder
von der aktie machen kann
und es gibt noch eine andere version ist
auch sehr etwas statista das ist viel
und sie wird immer ist das kapitel
ich glaube es einfach zeitraffer
seitenflächen 100 mal gekracht
schon jetzt wieder hier spielbar und
selbst danach knapp 172 gab es nicht
ganz nur gezeigt wo eigentlich der
computer das ist eigentlich auch nicht
der computer sind ist eine konsole leben
gekommen seien von angestellten
man muss sich anschauen worüber man
spricht das war der zeit der konsole
atari und dann in den achtzigern
nintendo ganz groß in tempo erst mit and
entertainment system das super nintendo
und dann sofort die hände und anregungen
der b 460 die 80er waren die zeit der
konsole und sega mega fans erweiterte
frauen erst in den neunzigern gelangen
auf basis des computers die waren ja
ganz an sachen vergleich von franz ohren
auch was die grafik chips überlegte
wirkliche computerspiele zu realisieren
den konsolen oft neben konnten zwar ist
das klassement
das ist das verfügbare einkommen
zwischen gewalt sondern es sind die tore
die meisten bieten kann zuschauer das
für ein soziales
eine schnecke die nummer ist hier auch
dass sie das
es gibt gerichte spielen das war das
erste was ich gespielt habe und das iss
kommando krise zeigen bereits acht jahre
am pc meines vaters im büromarkt ist
commander keen und sie sehen das hier
ist eines kro 1 2 disc oder also wir
können hier nur in einer als auch zwei
leben zu können und das zweite funktion
er verdiene es auch vergleichen sie das
mal mit dem spiegel
nachdem kategorie mini versionen gibt
versionen dokumentierten version statt
chance die szene
sie sind also dieses kleine der von
seiner
das leben mit der rakete auf anderen
planeten und dann hier gegen solche
komischen des gutes ding ist nicht böse
aber so größer schneller und dann das
darüber sprechen wir
dinge darüber sprechen denn seine
pistole lage sind einfach wie 415
version statt auch über die geschichte
des sympathischen antagonisten
protagonist ja das ist eine witzige
figuren importiert gezeichnete figuren
der commander keen zehnjährige junge 8
bis 10 jähriger junge der da im
traumschiff steigen und auf andere
planeten pflegt werden seine eltern
schlaf und daher ganz lustige dinge
erleben ganz lustigen figuren also es
geht doch über sympathie die
identifikation aber schauen sie die
version wird dadurch auch
problematisiert als es noch zwei der
sicht sie sind nicht aus der sicht
dieses comeback ins aktive sind sie
sehen ihn als jemanden den sie steuern
aber sie steuerten chance nummer komma
gekommen war hoch und runter hier können
sie jetzt brings und rechts zu können
hoch springen sie können schießen sie
können wir auf verschiedenen ebenen sie
können auch springen sie können auch in
diesem fall hier punkten
waffen aktion zusammengebrochen als es
ist viel dimensionale in der
beweglichkeit interaktion zur nächste
spiel erkennt dass das ist wolfenstein
3d und zwar auch aus dem jahr 1992 habe
ich nicht gespielt war nämlich
indizierte dargeboten
das spiel handelt eben davon ganze
dieser protagonist ist die letzte
sequenz des spiels dar denn fleucht
dieser protagonist ist eine gute aus den
nazis es geht um also da geht es darum
dass
hcs bis 7 und dass die letzte sequenz um
hier kommt ein 2 aber schauen sie mal
der anfang an da sehen sie gerne an die
sequenz die kommt jetzt so einfach wäre
sie bewegen sich dann mit einer waffe
nach vorne so eine runde kam damals
immer kleiner das war jetzt schon zu
sehr mitgenommen
das ist dies nicht aus seinen augen
sitzt was fällt ihnen jetzt auch bei
dieser sequenz im vergleich zur
vorherigen von commander keen
genau mal wieder genau wo wir alle
gerade dieser erste punkt das war auch
wieder wach und zwar aus der sicht
vieler wenn man sehr viel wasser halten
das ist natürlich hier schon von der
intention
das war eines der ersten glücklichen 3 d
spiele das heißt wirklich habe es das
mit vorsicht zu genießen deutlich weil
wenn sie mal hat die technik anschauen
es handelt sich hier verbremst dem
technologie play casting heißt er wird
nur eine simulation von 3d hergestellt
aber das ganze nur zweiter in der
disziplin zeigen wie das geht es jetzt
verboten gesehen
[Musik]
dass sich bauer und vergisst nicht von
werden verschiedene dass dies während
entschieden strahlung ausgesendet
aus diesem werk
das ist der pizza und die treffen auf
die wende
um die weitere wände entfernt umso mehr
weil sich diese stadt auf dass er für
die familie das wirklich braucht und wie
weit ist werden ist diese bestrahlung
hatte und aus diesem strahlenden fächern
wird dann eine projektion erzeugt die
sitzung das team wieder raus und das ist
eben diese blaumann ist größer weil der
strahlte so lange braucht ist er wird
oft und wie es erreicht werden
was sind schon ein bisschen einem
gläubiger also es ist er seither und
säbelzahntiger und das ist die beste
technologie
das war die erste
3d spiele waren nicht nur so simulation
auf zwei die basis das als baustein 3ds
war ist der erste spieler und jetzt kann
man hier das spiel das ist ein bisschen
brutal wird er um die hand geschüttelt
das ist kennen sie das
kennen sie das ist nun mal so 93 ein
jahr später
wir sehen hier gibt es mehrere levels
sequenzierung haben und wir haben die
waffen besitzen blieb also ob die
deutschen besser als ein jahr später
und jetzt habe ich in szene
weil aber das ist immer noch deutlich
besser also es kann ich mir jedenfalls
von mir uns sagen die künste von schon
das ist quatsch 14 19 690 das ist noch
deutlich besser gibt es das ist eine
echte 3d grafik und nicht mehr mit ray
3d modelle hier und jetzt schon dass wir
das
man hat gesehen dass man auch was jetzt
passiert
sie haben damit waffenrechts daheim und
jetzt sind sie da
richter dann machen sie zur elite
[Musik]
und was passiert am ende sind sie ganz
und das ist kennt man diese spielen das
ist eine der bedeutendsten entwicklungen
der neuerburger spielegeschichte und das
spiel kennt das jemand kann es bei
diesem projekt das es an lehrern und
sind 98 in meiner zeit
das habe ich oft abgespielt und es lief
nicht auf meinem pc so wohnt ich hatte
nur 106 wehrmacht megabyte ram und 250
gbyte festplatte aber es geht
einigermaßen
das ist eine szene wo man sieht wie kann
man wirklich richtig fängt einsätzen nie
im kino finden diese szene ist kurz
bevor der erste gegner auftritt also
eine künstliche intelligenz ein monster
was dann in dieser dunkelheit auf
einzuklagen
also man ist hier praktisch eingestellt
die richter geben
ganz dramatisch immer mehr aus dem sinn
jetzt geht das ausgeht dass aus dass das
von den senioren gern wird immer mehr
dunkel am ende ist alles dunkel und dann
kommen darf wenn wir das ganze ein
monster und gegen das muss sie kämpfen
das ist nur möglich durch ein neues
licht engine
wir glauben dass ein gerade die version
erreicht der dazu führen kann dass man
blickt hier schritt ich bin damals als
dann alles dunkel war dieses monster
kamera dieses monster wirklich sehr sehr
intelligent wenn man auf uns geschossen
hat stress zur anderen seite und so
weiter alles war wirklich eine der
besten künstliche intelligenzen auch im
mittelpunkt der hier realisiert wurde
dieses spiel anrufe von 1998
es war sein brücken und jetzt schauen
sie mal das ja sie waren ausgewählt
werden
bis 12 aber schon das ist die anderen
vier des projektes über 14 16 jahre
später dass es mit beste engine hat die
beste spiele spiele in der grafik
erzeugungsleistung engine heißt der
motor anspricht wirklich ausspielen von
engines das ist mit dem aktuellen beste
da kann man fast fotorealistische spiele
oder umgebung mit erzeugen schauen sie
mal die lichteffekte wie sicher das ist
so weit sind wir geblieben und das
wollten jetzt einfach nur mein wird kurz
als durch noch präsentieren
ja noch eine praktische anwendung das
mit dem leben anfangen kann wenn sie
sich da es gibt da von architekten
ingenieuren was man gebäude
und dass er plant nein die kann man
ebenso eine simulation dass man wirklich
quasi hast als du an der besucher durch
das gebäude durch gehen kann kennt sich
und man sieht einfach mein ding jetzt
hier sieht man ihr quasi angeboren ist
hier die frage ist in simulationen ist
in der realität müssen und die frage
jetzt wieder auf diese spiele handelt
sich dabei um eine simulation um den
fiktionen eine virtuelle realität würden
sie sagen
simulationen zu sagen was müsste denn
der fall sein dass man sagen können es
handelt sich dabei um ein wirtschaftlich
rentieren warum sind sie nicht bereit
das wie glaubens recht geben ein bezug
zu sehen
es ist eine sehr subjektive wahrnehmung
nichts von mir aber ich sie einfach da
habe ich die noch nie gespielt
das machen interessiert seien nur
spielereien hinterher
wann würde daraus
ja natürlich dahin sogar bediente
agieren kann dass es im realen leben ein
wunder schafft also überlegen sie mal
zum beispiel es gibt gewisse spieler
mehr miteinander spiele korrekt so weit
ist auch indiziert gewesen teil neue
sense ist nicht mehr wie gewalt
darstellen aus diesem wichtig diese
spiele kann man auch gegen andere
spielen im internet
und man kann dabei sogar ziemlich viel
geld gewinnen wenn man also viel geld
machen wenn man neben sich sehr gut
dabei schlägt und könnte man sich fragen
ob man sich dann mit ihren virtuellen
realität zu tun hat wenn man gegen
andere spieler also antreten könnte die
sie bietet spielt und am ende gegen
diese gewinnt oder saniert das hätte
eine gewisse unterwäsche passt es war
also gibt es möglichkeiten sich nicht
nur wohnen sondern hier wird wirklich
ein kampf ausgetragen auf und rangiert
damit auf den virtuellen konto
übertragen auf dem schachbrett das
sogenannte sehe ich eine weile spielen
achtungssignal geschafft werden jeden
hat ja auch eine gewisse orientieren sie
den markt kaufen wenn der himmel im
livestream 8
ich weiß nicht die 1000 leute zu und
nicht nur 9 wie banken und nicht nur neu
überlegt was nicht heißt dass es weniger
wäre das vergleichbare genau auf genau
genauso ist es ist nur so und das ist
sehr schnell die selbst sie sitzen
stehen über den figuren und sei es auf
dem monitor der antreten
bei diesen spielen sind sie wirklich aus
der wichtig interagiert für sie fremden
aussichtsreich und mit der waffe und
schießen auf gelangen das ist natürlich
genau dasselbe wie ein schachspiel aber
kommt noch mehr diese version
sie würden sich doch nicht nicht könig
oder mit der mannschaft identifizieren
mutterschaft wieder machen zu also um
exzellente weltmeister machen vielleicht
die fühlen
die lebenskraft vermietet dennis und der
spitze geschafft wie der das macht denn
das bitte sein posten
wie ordnen sie diesen kontext
die spot initiativen zum beispiel ein
bisschen ja auch den sie verbände
auseinandersetzen müssen wird es zum
beispiel
fußball ja genau das gehört das jetzt zu
viel quer und freunde
sdf 1 und computerspielen
fußballsimulation sagt man aber die
simulation werden wirkt ausgetragenen
turnieren des wortes elektronische
sportplätze kämpft wird dies auch dann
gibt es geld zu gewinnen und ich denke
schon dass es zufall dass in einem
gewissen geworden und rahmen stattfindet
wo vielleicht nicht nur eine person
gegen computerspiele sondern eben gegen
andere leute fassen menschen versuchen
antritt ich glaube ich könnte man bloß
aus wird
damit sprechen die frage ist natürlich
die ob wir irgendwann gleich ob wir den
regen mann zugute
künstliche intelligenz haben dass wir
sie gar nicht unterscheiden können von
recht mitspielen und ist auch die frage
und da diese diese form von krediten
das sind sie sollen erfahren wenn zwei
menschen geteilt oder zwei gläser genau
genug oder als mindestens so würdigte zu
qualitäten als ein wichtiger punkt auf
den hund gekommen bin ist eigentlich der
freiheit glauben müssen
freiheit heißt
man kann sich von raum und zeit lösen
freiheit bedeutung ist dem negativen
sind die unabhängigkeit von gewissen
physikalischen gegebenheiten die raucher
zeitung organisiert sind zum beispiel
der welt schafft es eine befreiung des
wertes wenn seine physikalischen basis
eine völlige loslösung auch eine
befreiung
es geht ja zu hause
dieses thema wo sie das gefühl haben
auch physikalisch das gefühl haben
mitten drin sind zum beispiel wenn sie
in die erste viertelpause das oben
genannte gibt das gefühl sie sie geben
sich auch so wenn sie von außen
beobachtet werden bis sie sich in die
kurve gehen oder sie haben das gefühl
dass der werden die kalisch kraft
bestimmt trotzdem hat fragen sich alle
im system sich dabei um eine virtuelle
realität und es beispiel oder nur mal
eine simulation was würden sie sagen da
bin ich schon eher von geld bar wird war
realität bei spielen auf diese
dimensionen ganz bestimmte rolle
sie sind
er gibt es ja andere effekte aufzubauen
wolkenkratzer und an den rahmen geführt
werden wir haben diese leute weg in die
garage
es gibt diese neue brille des opfers
will verkennt die devise
helau oder bank heißt sie haben damit
jedenfalls lebenswelt im psychologischen
ganz wichtigen geschrieben weil hier die
dimensionen so stark ist willkommen auf
dem begriff depression genau zu sprechen
dass man es wirklich für die handhelds
und es kann also durchaus positiv
gemeint also es gibt auch deutlich wie
zb höhenangst haben muss und damit
trainiert basierten virtuellen
[Musik]
ja und die gewöhnen sich daran können
ich würde es trotzdem ich als virtuelle
realität bezeichnet also damals einfach
zwei verschiedene ansichten also ich
glaube nicht dass man deswegen nicht
weil es immer noch inspiration ist und
eine sehr gute reaktion aber es fehlt
hier das jeweils geldscheine zu geld
gemacht und war es ein blauen karte in
seinem team und machte den 600 euro wert
ist
wir müssen doch genau bestimmen was das
ist ich glaube das ist eine hinter
subjektivität bis ins 20
und es muss was geben in der subjektiv
wieder das prägt das kann man dies von
credit suisse exporte man dafür dass das
virtuelle realität ist wie es ist wenn
du es mit mindestens zwei lesen haben
da ihr die an dieses abkommen treffen
des boards mit jeder zeit nicht
entschieden wer entscheidet also wer
sich künstlicher tricks bedient
entwickler uns dieses bank schon im
nächsten spiel schauen
es gibt es auch bei 3d spielen oder bei
strategiespielen dass jemand bietet also
bedeutung und wird wissen manipulationen
des todes erreichte vorteil er hat um
spielt das irgendwie weniger verletzlich
ist so dass er mehr dass er schneller
läuft oder das der band anders mit wenn
man sich auf solche regeln ein
dann wird die ganze sache rücksicht
ernst und und dann wird es mit der
außenwirtschaft erklären die presse
jetzt aus ökologischer sicht der noch
nicht bereit wäre diesen ganzen computer
spielen die wir jetzt auch hier gesehen
ab und zu fern sich nur um einzelspieler
verhandelt eine virtuelle realität zu
bestehen obwohl gehen die rede davon war
dass das geld in der firma tätig sein
ich glaube wir müssen nochmals strenger
unterschreiben aber wenn man das erst
aus der sicht des rezipienten und der
rezipienten sind alle die rezeptions
ästhetik muss immer auch das finden
benötigt kann dann kann man sicherlich
auch eine psychologische finden ist so
leben dass eine bestimmte gerade so
erreicht ist die person die ihr zustand
versetzt dass sie wirklich
unterschreiben oder
das konnte und auch so reagiert wie wenn
sie auf angeschlichen sie dort zu medien
würde aber der unterschied ist eben dass
wenn ich die person geht es hier keine
angst genannt laufen manchmal entsteht
ein hochhaus und ist nur einen meter
und wenn ich das gefühl habe ich angst
um auch wenn ich die version der wunsch
also teuer der mission stoße wird sie
sich erstmal schrecken kamen noch nichts
passiert
durch die geteilte unternehmen befrieden
und damit ist die regulation der
illusionen aufgelöst
die sports geld es anders wenn sie es
hinter suter gesellschaftliches anders
wenn sie die gesellschaftliche reisen
ist der wert bricht der regeln oder wenn
sie bis bord daneben schießen und
verlieren sie das preisgeld also ich
glaube schon dass einfach die konsequenz
die kasan an da absondert
710 aber spannendes thema auch von der
hose möchte hier so offen wie das
passieren
vielleicht ist auch mit den genomen
zusammenarbeit
ersten flügen piloten
ja das ist an dass das in den versionen
es sache des lernens auch ist der
gewöhnen müssten version oder punkte
also man kann natürlich sicher und alles
hinein denken man kann sie natürlich
auch eine ganze primitive zwei welten
denken wenn man es nur will so jetzt
möchte ich hier nach ende der sitzung
wir noch mal auf dieses neue spenden
kampagne des computerspiels gemeinsam
die sagen vergiss den blick die begriffe
die version interaktivität involvierung
gegriffen das feld der spieler bindung
jedenfalls dieses feld gehören
der begriff der präsenz sowie die figur
des avatars an diese spielfiguren über
die viele diese verbindung vermittelt
werden zb dieser commander keen diese ca
10 jährige junge mit diesem helm mit
dieser pistole der auf der strecken und
schießt der könnten als avatare bezahlt
werden wobei das eher unüblich ist vom
anstrich meist konstant von avataren
wenn es sich um spiele handelt indem man
eine bestimmte überspielen zb spielt
hier haben den kennt das jemand
diablo nachgespielt tja da sehen sie mal
wie es momentan gibt es drei glaube ich
alles wieder offen die am 3
und der spielte eigentlich nur auch von
oben von schräg von der seite und sie
steuern die mit der maus wo sie hingehen
zu können gewisse ausrüstungsgegenstände
und interagieren
das saunabad und diese avatar verändert
sich bekommt die weitere
erfahrungspunkte man kann seine
persönlichkeit lewis in richtung immer
entwickeln sondern stärker werden
funktionen mehr magie eigenschaft ist
dessen avatar und über diesen avatar
dass das medium werden für die
vermittlung erzeugt diese verbindung ist
unser endspiel des ersten vollzug des
spielens durch die ständige kommen und
so spielen als hardware software und
spiele social
im feld der stellen die auszeichnung die
wechselseitigen besuchen spieler die
spielen stellen den kern des spielens da
frage man sie handelt es sich hierbei um
eine neue dimension an der anderen art
von spiel wirklich in solchen mit kraft
spielt oder mit anderen spielen die
behandlungen spielen kann
ich glaube schon richtung schon lauter
ziemlich stellen der vermietung oder
stattfindet einem auch gut schachfiguren
sind auch amateure in einer gewissen
weise aber wir können aus dem könig wir
können könig nicht verändern
der könig kann sich nur so und so
bewegen wie die rede ist fest in der
bauer kann anfang 2009 maximal und dann
immer nur eins und halt immer nur
seitlich schlagen und sie identifizieren
sich auch nicht nur mit einer vergeben
chance 24 wieder infizieren sie in einer
farbe ordnung ganz wichtig wir sind
praktischen aufgeteilt es ist sein
erstes hier
während hier geht es nur um eine führung
mit der sich videos und diese figur die
ist nicht festgelegt durch bestimmte
regeln und die können sie ganz frei
entwickeln sie haben mit gewissen
freiraum und also freiheit spielte wolke
stellen aus dem raum ausgewichen sind
[Musik]
das ist glaube ich doch was neues was
ist super
[Musik]
die frage hat der in millionen von
spielern lässt sich kritisch anschließen
untersuchungen der immersion das heißt
es hineingezogen werden oder ein anderes
medium bis zum jahrtausendwechsel wurde
das phänomen
die version der literatur fühlen und
medienwissenschaftler mit dem
kunstwissenschaft irland ständen lernt
und klar weil mich die digitalität haben
als phänomen einer scheinbar
unreflektiert und rezeption und oder des
eskapismus steht es im gegensatz zum
distanzierter rezeption und der
distanzierung des traditionellen medien
wie sie im osten mit der denken
forderung stellt klar der postmoderne
das muss alles kritisch betrachten nicht
zu sehr identifizieren
es geht uns nicht um die frage was dann
der autor wollte der autor ist sowieso
tot und wir selbst zu halten wenn wir
einen normalen lesen wir lesen wir nur
einmal wissenschaften oder
anspruchsvolle ja ich sage ich dass es
richtig ist aber die literatur
professorinnen und professoren werden
nehmen sie robert musils mann ohne
eigenschaften liest und wider der crm in
der prüfung mündigen dass ihr den
protagonisten im juni so toll finden und
dass sie ganz mühelos kamen als im
unterricht immer wieder vor augen haben
werden uns in den unterricht so gute
einging und sich damit zu identifizieren
kann
sehen sie haben kennt wen um 1900
gewissen vor ihrem geistigen auge
erscheinen auto bis 400 200 projektes
geschichte meine leidenschaft sagt die
wirtin der literaturprofessor
auch versuchen zu sagen das ist mir egal
ob dieses schöne gut was sie dabei
denken empfinden und spüren und und was
sie dafür fantasien haben assoziation
das ist nicht das was ich von ihnen
wissen möchte ich möchte von ihnen
wissen sieht es in romanen konstruiertes
welche politischen prinzipien die straße
trieben mit einem durch das heißt die
folge man strukturell version ist genau
das gegenteil zur strukturanalyse
dimension ist totale aufgehen
das gewissermaßen rezipieren das nicht
vermittelt durch reflexion eine totale
aufgibt und dann wird gegen jede
literaturwissenschafterin zu recht sagen
das ist keine wissenschaftliche
herangehensweise da an einkommen und das
ist der unterschied zur version in
version als ästhetisches wenn möglich
geraten diese unmittelbar das fehlen der
reflexion haben möchte dass er wirklich
aufgeht sich direkt mit dem effizienten
unmittelbar durch digitale medien sowie
insbesondere durch türen zu und
experimente mit der virtuellen realität
nicht dass ich im streng sind in
realität anhalt ich glaube das ist nicht
präzis bekam das phänomen jeder und neue
aufmerksam
zu nennen sind insbesondere die studien
von zensur die vor allem und explosiven
haft eine textbasierte meter fokussiert
und oliver grau der visuelle stoff
prüfung kameramanns zur qualität
insbesondere der kunst untersucht sowie
der band immersion erzählt konnten als
eine konstant ihre der untersuchungs
linie jedoch mit anderer begriff fällen
wäre die app technologie studierte
forschung in version
diese dinge auf die virtuelle realität
zu verschließen
auch die gelben studies thematisieren
das thema ist und in den letzten jahren
verstärkt ich glaube dass computerspiele
eben das paradigma in der 12 eine
einheit die begriffsverwirrung ist aber
auch hier noch nicht zu finden
zuschlagen zb wahrnehmung franz mähr
mehr je ein dreitägiges schema das sc
team und ins tal und challenge
das zwischen sensorischer und
herausforderungen faszinierend dann auf
der ausbildung das
die argumente für die entscheidung karl
ecker entwickelt ein modell das sechs
dimensionen räumlichkeiten attraktiv
nativ performativ geteilt und zwei jahre
krankenakten fassen für eine genauere
erklärung besagt sie mit seinem gibt vip
gaming experience modell musste jedoch
nicht gänzlich sondern glimmt den
involvierten glauben und das ist jetzt
recht hilfe dieses nächsten versionen
das haben wir uns ja auch belegt als wir
diese computerspiele das angeschaut
haben räume ich ganz schnell aktiv
werden geteilt
diese noch eine weitere dimension die
verdienen die messung nicht
ich glaube dass der raum und interaktion
dessen schrecken aber schauen sie mal
erblickte noch taktil vielleicht war das
das anfassen betritt das gibt es
natürlich nicht
beim computerspiel gut ich kann ihm aus
anfassen
genau
genau da haben wir das ein bisschen am
text das ist beim zum beispiel konsolen
playstation oder auch das ist eher was
für eine konsole nintendo gibt es
vibrationen wenn ich zum beispiel im
auto an die wand fahre dann vibriert ist
dann habe ich hier was das nur
interessant sind das taktieren
aber wie sieht es aus mit gerüchten und
faktor ist
akustisch hab ich schon an welches sinne
bedient wird immer so muss immer in
unserem sinne also visuell ganz klar
dass amazon.com war professionell
ich weiß gar nicht ob es keinen
kommentar ich glaube sondern zu werden
erst wenn dieses dieser ballung store
ist gab es gar nicht
das waren gewiss wäre eine bar und
visuell ist vielleicht das wichtigste
für investoren auswählen und brauchen
wir akustisches warum wir taktiles als
er haptisches katholisch wie ich
eigentlich auch berichtet dass gibt es
noch schmeckt genau wie ich nun
schmecken ist
[Musik]
als quälix sich bis wir wirklich die
vollständige version erreicht haben also
alle unsere sinne müssten bedient werden
durch solche sachen gibt es übrigens
auch über links wie klavier gelistet
symbol faktor ist die vollständige die
vollständige version 10 1 ich glaube
hier will man uns dass ich damit dass im
virtuellen realität haben eine wirklich
sehr gute simulation das fehlt mir für
diese realität hier noch verwenden
die version wird erst seit einiger zeit
verstärkt wissenschaftlich beachtet und
bei einigen dieser arbeiten eine
historische ausrichtung mit der tendenz
einer teleologischen jedem
geschichtsschreibung zu beobachten
lassen
so wird die geschichte der medien von
verschiedenen autoren als versuch der
herstellung von immer perfekte
illusionen und immersion strategie
betrachten von grauen konstatiert dass
wie der europäischen kunst und
mediengeschichte seit dem ausgehenden
mit brüchen und umwegen immer wieder ein
wettstreit zwischen neue produktions und
bist als gräfin die zeit also wichtiger
punkt jedoch wenn wir diese sitzung ist
dass die version auf eine gewisse
ethische dimension bekommt dieses zitat
in einer logik der entsprechen die
perfekte illusion und diejenige ist die
man nicht gemerkt während esther
erstrebenswerte endpunkten milliarden
euro aussagen zur freiheit technologie
konstatieren dass diese endung unendlich
erreicht sie andere menschen viele
unterstützen den technologieaktien
gericht entwicklungen der ebene computer
zum krönenden abschluss der medien doch
weder entsprechend visionen für
abonnieren
in realen gegebenheiten noch sind sie
selbst die sind eben visionen und
besuchen die ihren neuen medien immer
wieder auftauchen punkt antreten patient
schon 146 in bezug auf den mythos vom
total feststellen
zur promotion
also ein ganzes jahr ist der computer
wirklich die krönung der technologie
oder nicht spannende frage
ich glaube jedenfalls das internet ist
die gründung einer technik oder drei
fluss sehr recht gezeigt hat weil es die
infrastruktur für alle seiten müssen
jetzt leider schluss machen
nächste woche fällt als seminar wegen
der tagung was ist digitalität raus sie
können aber gerne sich noch an welcher
für gebäude das der letzte tag und die
tagung wird auch live kilogramm tragen
das heißt sie können das alles mit
erfolg oder sich im nachhinein schauen
und dann sehen wir uns eben wieder zwei
wochen